I'll see I suppose the guys who don't
just do something they think about why
they're doing something when you watch
it an intense chess match and you're
seeing a battle of minds of battle
tactics that isn't even just on the
board it's five moves ahead 10 20 moves
ahead this ability for the action to
just kind of turn on a dime if you know
the person you playing you might know
what their favorite tactics are you know
you think I got that game wrapped up and
then all of a sudden two bases go down
another base gets billed they think
they've got you they've got their units
coming in and then you just drop death
out of the sky you build for long-range
siege you go air do you go heavy guns
what's my enemy doing how am I gonna
counter react to that times ticking down
the score is ticking up I've taken on
board what you've thrown at me now i'm
going to dismantle app
first thing I had to figure out it was
who we were going to work with on this
and my mind immediately went to Creative
Assembly they are synonymous with RTS
these guys been doing this for 20 years
they're still at the top of their game
we wanted to make this feel like a game
that was very much a sequel to the
original we already have a wonderful RTS
and we're trying to build on top of that
what we really wanted to do was add
layers of depth so the wide range of
players can have a fantastic time free
most players in go actually it's not
really that complicated it's a real
action focus strategy game we're also
doubling down on the size of these
environments I have the space to get
involved in some serious combat if you
want to practice your base strategy you
can go into domination you can go into
death match if I'm in the mood for a
fast game i can jump into strongholds so
we've got different kind of ways to play
the game for different kind of players
we absolutely want those hardcore
players and we've absolutely got games
and game modes that are suited to that
but then we've got on the other end of
the spectrum modes like blitz it's
something nobody's ever done before
blitz is a whole new way to play RTS
we're really excited about blitz it
really changes the way people will look
at RTS games blitz is a fast-paced
arcade action version of halo wars 2
where instead of building your army at a
base you're building them before a match
as a deck of card and you fight by
deploying cards from your hand into the
battlefield in real time there is no
base building there is no economy
management it's all about the combat I
don't want to worry about tech trees I
don't worry about resource collection
the original design attention for blitz
was to make something really accessible
that everybody could enjoy whether
you're new to strategy games or an RTS
veteran experience a really cool bits of
RTS a commanding a huge army bringing
down huge leader powers
it's all about playing the right card at
the right time at the end of the match
you're wielding these large forces with
all sorts of different powers and
abilities and start bringing out bigger
guns Marauders blister back even if
you're a really seizing vet it's such a
different way to play an RTS building a
deck is going to be heavily influenced
by the leader that you choose going in
you'll have a number of cards that are
unique to that leader trying to
differentiate each leader to make them
feel like they have a unique purpose and
a unique playstyle I tend to be a little
more aggressive when I play so I will
lead towards like an HR e ox or a
Decimus I like that we're taking a risk
we're making something really exciting
that I think people haven't seen before
you're playing with the units on the
field you're playing with the leaders
and the abilities I think it was of
taking on the player and you're reacting
to what their actions are you really can
turn the type
there's always an opportunity to kind of
pull back to your base shut down your
opponent's tactic and then come forward
with a strategy of your own as one of
the joys of RTS is the battles never
over till it's over